Vamos a cambiar tu vocabulario. ¿Qué fue
lo que yo comencé a hacer? Porque
entonces tiene que sostener, fue cambiar
la forma de comunicarme. Una de los
ejercios que trabajamos en incubadora,
¿vale?, que yo diseñé, ese empleado de
IA, ¿vale?, que utilizan mis
consultores, es, "Vamos a cambiar tu
vocabulario."
Si ustedes notan, la forma en la que yo
me comunico en 2025 no tiene nada que
ver con la que yo me comunicaba en el
2023. Así de sencillo. Y comencé a
agregar, pues, simplemente cosas
distintas. Por ejemplo, aquí en vez de
ayudo a marcas a crecer en digital, guío
a líderes a integrar la inteligencia
artificial con propósito. Fíjate,
líderes es un paragua más grande que
engloba todo, fundadores, empleados,
ejecutivos, pero también comenzamos con
los verbos. En vez de ayudar, catalizar,
¿vale? En vez de enseñar, transferir
sabiduría. Fíjate qué tipo de conceptos.
Entonces, es el tipo de ejercicios que
hacemos. Y yo le digo a la gente,
imprímete todo esto y tú lo practicas.
Lo que yo empecé a hacer literal era
antes de grabar un reel, yo me leía mis
palabras nuevas, me las leí y y me
sentía incómoda. Esta no soy yo. Hasta
que dije, pues, ¿por qué no me doy el
permiso? Porque yo ya sí era esa
persona. Pero es muy duro dejar [música]
una identidad antigua que te ha
sostenido para crear una nueva
identidad. Entonces, si vas a pasar por
eso, que sepas [música] que también para
mí fue un proceso de transición. Yeah.